[Music]
millions of people around the world
enjoy a hot cup of joe every day but why
do we all love this weird bitter taste
in theory humans should not enjoy the
taste of coffee because we're born with
a natural reflex to reject bitterness we
think this is because bitterness is
generally an indication of poison
so if coffee reminds us of poison why
are we drinking one theory is that
people consume bitter foods when it
provides some kind of pharmacological
benefit and one benefit it wakes us up
with a good dose of caffeine caffeine is
a powerful drug that not only gives you
that jolt of energy but it's also been
linked to improving overall cognitive
function when the positive feeling we
received from drinking coffee outweighs
the rejection of the bitterness our
bodies seem to be more willing to accept
the flavor but this isn't true of
everyone research has found that some
people may taste the chemicals that
produce a bitter flavor more intensely
than others people whose receptors are
less active than others may have a
better chance of accepting the taste of
coffee so if you enjoy coffee you're
working against nature telling you you
shouldn't but that kind of makes you
want it more now doesn't it
[Music]